good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 410 object class
safe special containment procedures as
CP 410 is currently held at site 23 and
Tamala G lab 14 Zita and maintained in a
1 meter cubed transparent acrylic glass
container the top of the container is
perforated with 33 1 millimeter holes to
allow for ventilation and features a
small hinged lockable hatch in its
center measuring 5 by 5 centimeters the
hatch utilizes a simple cylinder lock
which is to be rekey every three months
the hatch is to remain locked
unless SCP 410 is actively being fed or
constituent members of SCP for 10 are
being removed for or returned from
research applications every 24 hours a
visual inspection and inventory of SCP
for 10 and its constituent members is to
be performed and logged according to
level for archival standards by
designated observational staff any
increases or decreases in the number of
constituent members of SCP for 10 should
be reported to the senior researcher on
duty immediately every 12 hours a
document containing no fewer than 5,000
words in any language but possessing a
minimum syntactical orthographical
and/or grammatical error ratio of 1%
roughly 50 errors in every 5,000 words
is to be placed inside the container the
document should be removed after one
hour reviewed by a staff linguist with a
speciality in the language the document
was composed in and subsequently filed
in the SCP 410 feeding archive
food documents should be composed
specifically for the purpose of
sustaining the SCP 410 colony no
existing archival materials or official
SCP records should be given to the
entire SCP 410 colony under any
circumstances
a single individual from the 14 member
colony that comprises SCP 410 may be
removed for research and functional
application for a single - our activity
period daily with approval from the
senior researcher on duty no more than 4
members of the colony are to be removed
at any given time transport of a single
SCP for 10 colony member should be
facilitated by no fewer than 2 class 2
entomology staff using only an approved
SCP 410 transport module to do so the
current SCP 410 transport modules are 20
centimeter cubed transparent acrylic
glass containers perforated with 12 1
millimeter ventilation holes and each
featuring a hinged lid equipped with a
simple latch description SCP 410 is a
colony of 14 individual beetles
designated scarabeus scripter by staff
Coleoptera stocked er Langstrom each
measuring approximately 5 centimeters
and possessing a carapace color
variation from light blue to deep
emerald green a visual examination
reveals nothing distinctive from other
members of the genus scarabeus with
regards to their appearance number of
legs wings eyes etc dissection of a
single member of the colony by a trained
Coleoptera strode no discernible
anomalies in internal morphology with
the exception of a small additional
organ designated this script again by
dr. Langstrom capable of producing a
variety of fluids both caustic and inert
it is worth noting that following the
death and dissection of this member of
the colony a replacement beetle larva
was seen 14 days later and grew to full
maturity within one month members of SCP
for 10 appeared to subsist entirely on
inscribed language more specifically on
syntactical orthographical and
grammatical errors found in any form of
writing physically inscribed on any
surface by any currently available
method SCP 410 has no effect on
electronic displays or digitized theta
consumed writing disappears from the
surface of whatever material that has
been inscribed upon between 18 and 22
minutes following a feeding SCP for 10
will excrete corrected writing in
scribing it by unknown means back upon
the surface from which the errors were
consumed to date all Corrections made by
SCP 4:10 have been evaluated as 100%
accurate by both staff and independent
orthographies and linguists individually
members of SCP for 10 each seem to be
able to consume and correct an
approximate maximum of 25 thousand
characters worth of errors daily and
appear healthy and active with as few as
5 lack of sustenance for a period in
excessive one day results in increasing
lethargy until a CP 4:10 becomes
completely inert and during an apparent
state of hibernation SCP for 10 can be
roused from this state with a minimum of
50 errors placed within its proximity in
groups of three or more SCP four 10 will
not only correct grammatical and
orthographic errors but begin to alter
the style of the original text slightly
often using a somewhat expanded
vocabulary and incorporating more
complex narrative methods when the
entire colony is applied to a single
document all linguistic errors are
corrected and the document is perfected
in
clarity style word choice and rhetorical
technique to such an extent that the
original author's voice is nearly
non-existent although the central thesis
of a document always remains the
arguments supporting it may be vastly
more complex or compelling in the case
of research writing in the case of basic
lists of short statements or simple
observational reports enhanced
correction may be in the form of layout
alterations to provide greater clarity
see archival files for 10 a 44 2 through
4 10 a 59 8 88 6 for examples of editing
there appeared to be few limitations of
the languages or materials that SCP 410
can interpret and harvest sustenance
from hieroglyphs from the 31st century
BCE Narmer palette were successfully
corrected by SCP 410 just as easily as
errors created in the modern constructed
language Esperanto excreted Corrections
match the original colors method and
medium of the errors with near perfect
accuracy graphite sinks engravings acid
etchings and high-energy laser
inscriptions have all been successfully
replicated in appearance by a CP for
tens Corrections the only anomaly found
within the excreted Corrections appears
to be an inability to replicate aged
materials errors inscribed an ink on a
14th century see illuminated manuscript
were ingested by SCP 4 10 and while
corrections were excreted in a matching
color they possessed the vibrant
intensity of new ink staff experts were
easily able to spot the corrections in
the manuscript visually and
spectrographic analysis confirmed that
the excreted inks were modern while the
surrounding text dated from the time of
the original manuscript
SCP 4 10 has successfully harvested our
sustenance from
and excreted corrections on to the
following materials paper cardboard wood
ice human skin see experiment 4/10 7.9
granite limestone marble steel aluminum
titanium and beta carbon nitride
proposed testing of SCP for 10 with
anomalous texts including texts
containing a CP 423 is currently pending
review experiment 410 7.9 1 heavily
tattooed Class D exposed to one
Constituent member of SCP 4 10 class T
staff member here after subject D
possessed a prison created tattoo with
the words Forever Yours baby on her left
forearm 15 seconds subject D secured an
emotion restricting harness and fitted
with a pulse rate monitor one can stitch
you in a member of SCP 4 10 removed from
transport unit and placed on subject d's
left arm 49 seconds SCP 4 10 begins
circling the perimeter of the tattoo 122
seconds as CP 4 10 begins consuming the
tattoos error beginning with the first
extraneous e in forever subject D
indicates an 8 on the NRS 11 pain scale
pulse rate reaches 106
149 seconds SCP for 10 finishes
consuming the first extraneous e it no
longer appears on the subject revealing
a bear patch of slightly reddened skin
subject D reports penas ceased describes
the pain like putting my goddamn arm in
a blender pulse rate 94 224 seconds as
CP for ten finishes consuming errors in
the tattoo appears to fall asleep tattoo
now reads foe ever your Bab subject D
experiences pulse rate fluctuations
between 102 and 144 reports pain ranging
from between 6 and 10 on the NRS 11
subject D requests painkillers request
denied 1200 26 seconds as CP for 10
rouses begins excretion and correction
process subject DS pulse rate 1 1 3
reports NR s 11 rating 3 2 4 describes
it as roughly analogous to being
tattooed 1494 seconds SCP 4 10 completes
excretion and correction process tattoo
reads forever yours baby with corrected
letterings colors significantly more
vibrant than unedited counterparts you
know it's weird I heard a lot of people
talking about how good it would be to
have a beetle 2 corrected things when
really this thing is a living clipping
you know that little paper clip in
Microsoft Word that everybody hates
these beetles are the living
representation of that do you really
want these things walking around doing
the real-life equivalent of oh I see
you're writing a letter now you need any
help there but you mean let me help
hmm I certainly don't
anyway I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert GM's
Sabha arbiters soul Darius
Tom Kareem l oz mooing Justin day o
philia gray Thomas Morin Curie kuma
Aaron Peck and jayvo Jack dr. crystal
spice my archive curator Nick Joseph
Lewis ooh agent vamp King modding and
dr. Proctor thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volga thank you
you